things are snowballing at the University
of Pennsylvania tonight Ross Stevens who
had pledged $100 million to the school
res sended the donation in a scathing
letter and they had an emergency Board
of Trustees meeting as well this was
after the school's president Liz McGill
set off a firestorm when she and her
colleagues from Harvard and MIT
literally could not find it within
themselves to Clearly say that calls for
genocide are not acceptable on campus if
is directed and severe or pervasive it
is harassment so the answer is yes it is
a context dependent decision
congresswoman well her hostage tape
clarification sounded completely
disingenuous afterward in that moment I
was focused on our University's
long-standing policies aligned with the
US Constitution I was not focused on but
I should have been the irrefutable fact
that it call for genocide of Jewish
people is a call for some of the most
terrible violence human beings can
perpetrate it's
evil plain and
simple couldn't she just memorize it
she's reading it off of her computer
screen this is the president of the
University of
Pennsylvania what's mindblowing here is
that this woman still has her job at the
end of the meeting this afternoon at the
Board of Trustees she was reportedly
still in her position as president a
source telling the Pennsylvanian as
usual nothing happened it was just an
opportunity for people to State their
opinions opinions is there actually
bored empathy with the president
regarding her testimony if a corporate
CEO did something to lose the company
$100 million and acquitted himself as
she acquitted herself well his office
would have been boxed up that night
joining me now as former Georgetown
professor ozra nanii and Chris rufo
senior fellow at the Manhattan Institute
ozra congresswoman stefanic gave her
multiple opportunities to change her
answer she only went back and did that
hostage tape clarification because of
the Firestorm that brewed otherwise she
would have just moved on to you know the
next embarrassment yeah she needs to
become former president Mcgill and what
is so important for people to realize is
that those testimonies is a
manifestation of six Decades of work by
Muslim organizations that have as one
mission in their lives the destruction
of the state of Israel and the removal
of Jews from The River To The Sea they
have established Beach heads at our
universities from Harvard to UC Berkeley
and they are the ones that have
Unleashed this woke Army onto our
campuses calling for the genocide of
Jews and that's unacceptable yeah well
Chris you know I know you and I aren't
surprised by this I mean I saw this
nonsense Brewing back in the mid 80s at
Dartmouth College okay that's how long
I've been watching this happening but
but we're seeing this attempt to
dominate campuses with this political
islamist anti-American anti-semitic
thought it's not just it's not just
anti-semitic that's bad enough it's
anti-American and anti-christian as
well that's right and it all stems from
the logic of so-called intersectionality
which deems any group with power any
group uh that has high achievements uh
the oppressor and any group that is at
the bottom of the socioeconomic ladder
the oppressed and you're supposed to
automatically side with the oppressed
and so University presidents have
twisted their minds in this left-wing
logic so that they find themselves not
just supporting black lives matter in
the summer of 2020 but they're now also
supporting Hamas uh in in these final
moments of 2023 uh because they're
trapped ideologically and they can't get
out of this trap I think congresswoman
stefanic had a brilliant gotcha here uh
and it really exposes the rot at the
heart of Academia these are people that
are very credentialed but but they're
moral morons uh they need to be removed
from power and the incentives have to
shift dramatically within Academia well
isn't this ozra the opportunity for
Congress to keep this going I mean I
this sh can't be a one-off I would bring
in the presidents of all the other
schools where this nonsense has been
taking place where where uh views have
been shut down by of conservatives uh
but this has obviously been allowed to
Fester really quickly yeah I am so
excited that um represent stonic is
going to subpoena universities across
the country and I just tweeted out to
her and said I'm exhibit a if you want
I'm ready to help you however I can
because I we know where the receipts are
buried and they are there well ozra and
Chris I think this is the beginning of a
long battle it can't be just everyone
applauding what just happened this week
pressure has to be brought to these
Board of Trustees these Boards of
overseers and uh that's where real uh
opportunity is and the big donors they
got to step up ozra and Chris thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else